[Music]
we'll meet again
don't know where don't know when
but i know we'll meet again
some sunny day hello i'm johnny
knoxville welcome to jackie
three two one
a lot of people ask what will jackass be
like once we're older
well it'll get more mature
the faster you pedal your bike the
faster the other guy's hand goes back
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything concussions aren't great
but as long as you have them before
you're 50 it's cool
and knoxville is 49 so we're good
[Applause]
can you feel my heart wow
today we're going to do a little
furniture shopping
i've been watching jackass since i was
12 years old
and guess what we're here
we have winners and we have steve a
bunch of nasa sciences right
what did you guys do to eric fail to
prepare
prepare to fail
you still got those million dollar teeth
that's for sure
gee didn't set myself up for failure on
this one
aaron please relax i'm trapped
and you're putting honey on me and
salmon
oh my god
oh my gosh
[Music]
huh